it kind of sounds French yeah chaddy
cushion Chevy wow I really don't know a
lot about Egypt not to mention their
food I don't know what their food could
be King Tut
there's pyramids yeah he was there yeah
they're gonna be falafel and stuff no no
yes looks so good what onion oh yes oh
my god I love fried onion mmm-hmm yep
yep
I could eat this every day I'm here
thought about mixing rice and pasta yeah
usually I don't accident when I drop it
but here it's just delicious we're about
to eat
Hoshi Hoshi how long see it's like how
is she I wish how out she Wow yeah this
is really good this is how Wow Wow oh
I'm gonna dip it in something yeah I
wish it was dipped to this molohia
walla hair it's like you're Hocking a
loogie yeah oh it looks like it would be
mole oh yeah
however just like there's a layer of
grease on love it it tastes really good
but like the moment it touches your lips
it like goes all over your lips yeah
makes like a mmm like doubles as a lip
balm please not is it like Mother's Milk
hahaha I love this mm-hmm
this is like heaven on earth it tastes
like old cereal
I love old cereal my mom wants to fatten
me up she can make this yeah all my
leaves my favorite omelly sounds like a
really cool wrapper
I would absolutely have this again me
too yeah I could totally see like a huge
dinner table and like everything is
portion off family style and you're like
passing it down you like scoop a little
bit of this you scoop a little bit of
that like yeah it's great I liked it